So, it gets really deep. I've done
sessions on this, but I'll do it again
in the future. Every man praying or
prophesying with his head covered
dishonors his head. This is the context
of veils, which we'll revisit in part
two cuz you said she brought it up. But,
I just want you to be
aware of this passage that's misquoted.
Every woman who prays or prophesies
bareheaded dishonors her head. For it is
one and the same thing as if she were
shaven. Now, get any good commentary on
the historical cultural context of
Corinth.
The only women who went around shaving
their heads were
or unruly rebellious women.
So, Paul is saying, you're not unruly
rebellious
So, the last thing you're going to do is
shave your head. But, if you're not
going to cover your head, then shave it.
Well, you know you're not going to do
that, then you have to have your head
covered.
You understand the logic of Paul? Right.
Yeah. Okay. So, now let's continue.
Therefore, if the woman is not covered,
let her also be shorn shave it.
And if it is a shame for a woman to be
shorn or shaven, let her be covered.
For a man ought not to cover the head
being the image and glory of God.
Reflect God's glory that he's your head
and you reflect him.
But, the woman is the glory of man. Now,
here's where it's misquoted. For the man
is not from the woman, but the woman
from the man. For the man was not
created for the woman's sake, but the
woman for the man's sake. Uh-oh, Paul,
you sound like a misogynist. No.
He's stating a fact. Note again, Paul
accepts the historical accuracy of
Genesis. He believes Genesis is real
history. So, those of you know your
Bible,
did God not create the woman to help the
man?
Everyone with me here?
You got about 15 minutes, right? So, I
can impact this.
>> Yeah, sure, sure, sure. Yeah, of course.
Did God not create the woman to help the
man? So, Paul is echoing Genesis means
he reads Genesis. He knows the context
of Genesis.
Wasn't the male the first one created?
Yes.
Why was the woman created? For the sake
of the man, but remember why? Because
man being alone, it wasn't good. So,
Paul's going to show you woman wasn't
created because she is deficient and man
is superior. It's the opposite.
Woman was created because man was
deficient without her.
Genesis 2:18. Right here. And Paul is
quoting Genesis and he knows his
audience knows Genesis.
So, they know the background. Also, the
Lord God said, "It is not good that the
man should be alone. I'll make a perfect
mate for him." Notice, woman was created
to fill a need in man because it's man
who's deficient without the woman.
But, it is a fact.
Women were created for men.
But, it was created because man without
the woman is deficient. You see, ladies?
God is telling you in a perfect world,
you complete man and man without you is
incomplete.
And I'm going to show you that Paul
agrees with this. Let me finish it.
Because of this, ought the woman to have
power upon her head because of the
angel. Now, since you are in submission
to your husband, show that submission.
Cover your head showing that you're
taken. Now, understand,
the veil for the woman is a sign to
others, I'm spoken for, I'm taken.
This veil shows I'm in submission to my
husband so that I belong to someone.
Eyes off.
You understand the wisdom? Okay.
Now, how do I know Paul is not degrading
women? Number one,
I want you to catch carefully, just like
men can prophesy and pray in the church,
he assumes women can do likewise.
When you're in church, women pray with
the men. You ladies know that when you
go to liturgy, are you silent?
When you're in church, the bishop can
give you authorization to say something.
Right here.
Just like men pray and prophesy, so do
women. That's somewhere. Number two,
I want you to think logically with me
before I read verses 11 to 16.
It says that man is the image and glory
of God, but the woman is glory of man.
Now, remember Paul is quoting Genesis.
He knows Genesis.
But, you need to think deeply.
If woman is the glory of man,
she's she's supposed to reflect the
glory of man, right? Honor the man whose
glory she is.
But, man is the glory of God,
then by extension, this means the woman
is also the glory of man. Note the
logic.
Man is the image and glory of God.
Woman came out of man. That's what he
just said.
Okay.
For the man was not created for the
woman's sake, but the woman for the
man's sake. That's why the woman came
out of man. Okay, now let's follow
logic. If man is the image and glory of
God and woman came out of man,
that means if she came out of man
and she's the glory and image of man,
that means by extension, she's the glory
and image of God because man is God's
glory, God's image, but if the woman is
in the man and came out of the man, that
means she too is God's glory, God's
image because to be the glory of man is
to be the glory of God.
You guys see the logic? Yeah. Yeah.
Everyone got it?
Masha Allah. Beautiful.
>> I'm going to now prove I'm right that
I'm not just twisting Paul's words. But,
let me know you guys are getting it.
You guys are getting it? Ladies?
You follow the logic? Okay, but now let
me prove to you
I'm representing Paul fairly because
people stop here. But, wait, why didn't
you read 11 to 12? Nevertheless, though
what I said is true, it's incomplete.
Let me give you the complete picture.
Neither is the man separate from the
woman. AH.
NOR THE WOMAN separate from the man.
They are both interdependent and they
depend on the Lord.
And yet though it's true that the woman
is from the man, so is the man also by
the woman. But, all things are from God.
You see what he said? It is true.
The first woman is from the first man,
but that's the only time
a woman came out of man because now
everyone comes out of a woman. So,
woman,
you're now
one step ahead of man and you did man
better than he did you. Why? Cuz only
one time in history did a woman come out
of man. Now, everyone comes out of a
woman,
whether man or woman, which means you
got the upper hand. In point of fact,
the greatest man who ever lived, who is
God in the flesh, came out of a woman.
Wow.
>> The last Adam came out of
Mary
and the last Adam is infinitely greater
than the first Adam. So, though Eve came
out of the first Adam, the last Adam,
the greatest Adam, the one who's God in
the flesh, came out of a woman. And
hence showing that Paul is not a
misogynist. Wow.
>> Paul is completing the picture and
showing you, yes, it's true, you woman
came out of
man, meaning the initial woman.
But, now
every other man comes out of a woman. In
fact, everyone comes out of a woman.
Even the last Adam, the greatest Adam,
who's God in the flesh, came out of a
woman.
You see how Paul completes the picture?
Wow. Gorgeous. I haven't I haven't
looked at it in this passage in that
way.
I had to because Muslims were misquoting
this in the beginning. And where do you
find all this information?
Let me show you where. On my website
here, I have sections on women in Islam
versus Christianity. So, let me get it
to you and Lord willing, we'll have more
to say in part two. Now, did everyone
get this?
Everyone got that Paul is not dissing a
woman. He actually elevates women. He
goes, "Nevertheless, it's true, woman
came out of man, but now
men need women as women need men and all
men come out of woman because if there's
no woman, there'll be no men.
And if there's no men, there'll be no
woman.
So, if you go here to this page, let me
get you the link.
So, thank you, Abdullah, cuz you gave us
another opportunity to glorify the true
God who lives and show the Bible is his
word, historically accurate and it's
superior to your Quran. So, here it is
for you in the private chat. When you go
here to the main page, all you do is
scroll down to find women in Islam,
women in the Bible. So, you do command
and control F. Doesn't the Bible degrade
women? No. And then here, women in Islam
parts one, two, three, and four, women
in the Bible parts one and two. Now,
most of the Hadiths are Sunni
traditions, she won't accept them.
That's why I focused just on the Quran.
I showed her from the Quran, the Quran
disrespects women.
Here you go, brother. Glory be to the
all holy trinity, man. Gorgeous.
Now, women, give us feedback. All you
sisters, leave some comments and make
sure you go to his YouTube channel. Tell
us,
after seeing what the Bible says about
women,
what is your reaction?
And remember, this is the revelation of
the triune God, Father, Son, Holy
Spirit. This revelation of Jesus, the
Son of God, who became flesh from the
Holy Virgin, making this virgin the
greatest of all creatures, our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ. And remember, if
you have not gone to Vartan's YouTube
channel,
I tagged him. Let me see if I can get
there before the rapture.
Tagged him.
Go there, subscribe
cuz he's got some great videos by some
great scholars. None of them as handsome
or as great as me, but nonetheless, we
are humble.
Cuz he's got some right here.
Boom. Go there.
Give me a shout out.